hate leads to suffering hell over there
reject nation I'm not doing this as well
as I'd like to we're gonna watch the
Mandalore it's failed fail yes season 1
episode of 5 people come here for the
bad impressions John I do all right I'm
excited to check this out want to thank
Eric over at nerd cronic for editing
this for us especially with the crazy
weekend he's having cuz he edits for
people like the movie trivia Schmo down
aqus on Iman snow has podcaster ever
podcaster found YouTube only allows for
10-minute reaction highlights if we're
lucky conceit if it's up our full length
reaction stream along its ready a sync
up with the time code that is available
at our patreon page go to our patreon if
you want to watch watch along with us
and last thing I want to mention before
swinging into this since the mandalorian
is weekly make sure to subscribe and
click that notification bell so you can
get notified when our next man direction
is up anywho let's do that
[Music]
oh wow this looks great yeah breaks my
life that was very satisfying how I was
great was very satisfying fanservice
I guess I just reached the prequels so
these effects look insanely amazing
before just remember ya know droids
I heard you you don't have to say it
twice hello Heather's sleazy mechanic
personalities so it's a trade of
everyone who don't have that trait it's
universal literally personality comes oh
there it is
[Laughter]
starwars whimsy music how do I know what
it is give me a second I am going to
look after you until the mandalorian
gets back and then I'm gonna charge him
extra watching you
she kind of looks like Alan Ripley's
unfortunate sister yeah her name's Toro
[Music]
come on relax name Star Wars Star Wars
name that's me now when agent May Fennec
Shand is an elite mercenary she made her
name killing for all the top crime
syndicates including the Hutt's you go
after her
he won't make you past sunrise this is
my first job yes you can keep the money
all of it and give me the tracking
father
don't worry got it all memorized you
trust this Cour no not at the moment
this guy can I get some vibes from
Unforgiven with this one you can't just
leave a child all alone like that you
know you have an awful lot to learn
about raising a young one I honestly
don't know what it eats Matt required to
truly keep it alive what do you think
not too shabby huh
Oh God his [ __ ] you want to be I don't
know I feel like he's been epilating him
right Rhys gotta be either that or cool
to see these back really uh every time
they say a Star Wars thing I'm just
gonna poison the original movies these
were some of my favorite gadgets oh yeah
dude
now Return of the Jedi was my favorite
as a kid then I got a little older oh
yeah so no with a cape he just looks so
much cooler than the other guy yeah
they're gonna bump into the genie in
Aladdin in a second that's right yeah
breeze right past him there the locals
else is just trespassing Oh whatever
they call themselves
they just keep their distance yeah why
don't you tell them yourself it's gonna
crap out of me
they appear let me see the buy knocks
why
by knocks hey what come on man you could
put this together
brand new yeah they were yeah
look I know early like 15 minutes in but
this is shaping into my favorite episode
all righty I can't tell ya see how it
ends
hey why do you find another bounty
hunter
hey plan on keeping all that self only
an MK modified rifle could make that
shot this guy's like huh interesting
learning a lot today come on wake up
he snuck out of the arm ha ha
[Music]
now
nice oh this is a two-man job they're
gonna
no no the man has our steel
she's got a child oh you should just
shoot her dude dude just shoot her IEP
whoa she's sarcastic in this episode
love it what is the plan I need you to
go find that dude back we saw and leave
you here with my bounty and my ride yeah
I don't think so mondo
dude man they're just the whole reason
she's caught no you wouldn't have got
her
I hired mando this is my job bringing
you in will make me a full member of the
bounty hunters guild you already have
something the guild values far I think
you said that three times his armor
Alone's worth more than my bounty I
already told you I don't care about the
money
then think what it would do for your
reputation oh you mean your name will be
legendary
oh this is written really oh really well
can't trust nobody out here in these
Star Wars streets you want to be a
bounty hunter make the best deal for
yourself and survive stop listening to
everyone dude
if we're gonna be a bounty hunter can't
think for yourself whoa
that's good advice
if the Mandalorians worth more than you
are well who wouldn't want to be a
legend kid
oh that was unexpected
yeah well done show well done
she straight up dead or she just like
knock down I get it John you're woke
that's what I want to establish with
that questions as a bummer
yeah me now wedding yeah didn't show
cool [ __ ] oh you I feel like man who
could easily shoot him in the head yeah
what's the damage if you drop a baby
you're probably fine
gonna cruise right bring you in won't
just make me a member of the guilt
legendary legend and I'll never have to
live up to it past this moment nice hats
right back on yeah dumbass where is it
Oh is there something it's grown up now
teenager take it you didn't get paid
[Music]
cover me
[Music]
[Laughter]
can't keep a Jame down hahaha its
Giancarlo Esposito character probably
it's so big good guess yeah
alright there's so much to talk about so
many Easter eggs man familiar droids
Tatooine the canteen cantina the speeder
bikes him sitting like Han and that one
booth that huh I have a forma clunky the
the Tusken Raiders before it happened to
our review of the show I did want to say
a thank you to our loyal patronage X for
being the patronage X matter patreon we
do weekly Q&A s and like I said we have
the stream along for the Mandalorian we
do stream along for many shows to name a
few Cobra Kai season 2 agents of shield
state arresting season 3 Gotham and then
their shows at our patreon that have a
stream belongs and they also have
reaction highlights like kind of like we
saw for the Mandalorian attack on side
and supernatural connor hunter my hero
academia move me included Death Note and
Cody s and there's been other shows as
well thank you patronage X was being bad
any him yeah I really did think this
episode was it was pretty great I like
how simple it was I mean it caught the
gunslinger is this appropriately named
it did remind me of like classic
westerns and there were vibes that I was
sort of getting from Unforgiven the
older Bounty Hunter older gunslinger
working with the younger kid which is
like kind of a Western shrub in itself
to tour ahora
Tonto at first I was I thought he might
have been like annoying as his
personality was going obviously he's not
supposed to be like the loveable
character in this episode the actor did
a really good job he brought a lot of
that narcissism ego but in a rookie kind
of yeah yeah yeah who thinks he deserves
more like the guy who wants all this
Attis without truly earning it without
truly achieving it relying on others for
the most part I've heard this like
common complaint going around that for
all these like sticky situations by the
end of every episode someone else saves
mandos life but in this episode it was
cool how to edit and look at John
McClane thingy he's thinking quick on
his feet
yeah he's able to take him down well he
came prepared yeah exam my back is that
could happen it's like yesterday news
the situation a bit but yeah he does
really figure his own way out yeah and I
love the writing of this episode I
thought the dialogue was so much fun
like the tone established and the very
beginning with this cool one-on-one
space battle you know they had some of
that kind of like action trope cheesy
dialogue yeah that's my line yeah but
then as it when I thought the characters
of African Amy Sedaris is character name
but Amy Sedaris is character I thought
she brought so much life to it and so
much personality and the Toro character
mando you got to hear more of his humor
I don't know what happened at the end
there I don't know if she's still alive
Bennett character may not one's
character it feels a little wasted if
she's not yeah if they really just
killed her off that does feel like a bit
of a waste I mean it's a good moment
like I wasn't expecting her to just cap
her on the spot but yeah I do hope that
maybe that cliffhanger is gonna suggest
that she's not all dick I'm not sure if
I would be bothered by it if it wasn't
me no I feel like I still be bothered
cuz you got like build up this character
it seems like a really cool threat
yeah like the establishment on the vibe
of what's going on within the bounty
hunters and the guild when she is
captured kind of trying to provoke mando
mmm it made sense with her character
that she would trying to manipulate Toro
of a surprisement Toro did you yeah it
made sense with the character but in the
moment it really it really threw me for
a loop yeah you get to watch a bunch of
people in this episode who are really
out for themselves in different ways and
watch the chaos that that can cause
that's the great thing that percolates
tension too because you've got him and
Toro and you're always sitting there
glad Toros gonna do something dumb yeah
he's gonna do some rasher tour he's
gonna do somebody thinks his badass he's
gonna ruin this and I'm glad that that
didn't happen they were able to keep
that spirit but make him actually kind
of a sinister presence or a moment bring
him back the speeder bikes here it was
pretty neat hey Bob
was killed on tattooing
dude maybe we'll find his body somewhere
and have like a memorial money but I
thought it was cool like with going
through the deserts attaching me kind of
seen where where it's at host Return of
the Jedi like Italy great people at the
cantina snow at the cantina nobody kept
the stormtrooper helmets on spikes was
like a disturbing image then even doing
sort of the desert hunt I thought was
neat having to look over sand dunes and
like these mounts and then bumping into
the Tusken Raiders it's just cool to
having like that open field exposed and
it's like you spot something pull over
you know yeah check it out keep going
around pull over
check it out I thought it was a cool huh
yeah that's one of the coolest parts of
the show I think is just the element of
discovery and the amount of space in the
world that you get to see because yeah
it's like we go to Tatooine really good
Tatooine but at the same time I love
that we spend so much time just in
desolation kind of in the middle of
nowhere I'm wondering if maybe this
might segue into a sort of two-part
episode of some kind because this is the
first one that seems to have like a
directly connecting cliffhanger so that
seems like something that could be cool
too because right now each of these
episodes has been very contained and you
have basically the baby Yoda are they
gonna come find him being the serialized
drama and stuff like that but I think it
would be cool to have something carry
over for like two episodes or something
like that that has to be Giancarlo
Esposito x' i we're managing yeah it has
to be and i mean in the trailers you
know he's in the desert so it would make
sense well i also really love the idea
too of he's being hunted he's a fugitive
now he still needs to make money
all he knows how to do is hunt is via
bounty hunters wow he's a fugitive he's
still like I need work do you make some
money you know maybe I can find a guy
who doesn't know what I did I think
that's really clever that way you can
still kind of guess some of these
episodic like elements keep it engaging
in that way but I think that's why they
also threw on the cliffhanger here
that's kind of what these last couple
episodes have done cliff-hanging it a
little bit it's like the first three
were pretty serialize the fourth episode
was very standalone had it had at a good
time cliffhanger and this one had a
cliffhanger too
love it as I just love checking in with
it with this tone in the world and baby
Yoda is still gonna rock fighters so
cute it's starting to become a little
product D to me yeah I mean I'd still
love the baby Yoda but this episode
especially was the was the first time I
was like now it's time to just feel like
an advertisement for for like toys
instead of really enhancing and you
can't really do much right now I get it
baby Oda is important yeah it's a
conundrum yeah it's a cute thing where
your mind is just immediately trained
especially nowadays to go this is you're
trying to sell toys and stuff at the
same time I wonder if people hadn't
people work freaking out and like buying
up Funko pops like it was nothing would
it be as distracting right exactly
because I wonder if that's playing into
my mind on that yeah and I don't know
because they the thing is even without
the legacy of Star Wars merchandising
you could still be reasonably accurately
cynical about the hey yeah I mean I did
like at least these sort of side quests
that became for Amy Sedaris sure and I
like that that has turned into something
icky you know it's like she does kind of
exploit him something I'm gonna charge
for keep taking care of you but it
became something that wasn't oh she's
just gonna double-cross him and
everything oh yeah good point good point
well John I had already said my opinion
though oh I'm sorry I take it before you
said your opinion forget I said no no
that's not what I'm saying I'm saying
that I don't for a moment there I was
gonna go away you changed my mind on
baby Yoda in the moment but because I
already made an opinion I now have to
fight I can't just go oh wait a minute
John made a good point I am persuaded
mine you can't change your mind do this
it's kind of weakened it can't take in
new information and apply it to what you
already knows and I always do it in
America seeing a mind builds up the
strength with it lock this all right
close it off and never did I stab at
someone I don't know
their opinions are on the internet
you're offended I'm still sitting here
wondering what the overall of the show
is going to be and I don't remember how
many episodes this is but even so I mean
that's percolating at the back of my
mind is is this gonna like nail some
kind of big ending but at the same time
I am just really enjoying the fact that
we are just kind of living in the life
of what a bounty hunter in Star Wars
universe gets to do I mean you're
sitting yeah in these you know you're
sitting in the ship all alone in the
first part of the episode you feel the
silence after the firefights done is
he's like switching everything back on
and then you're the desert and you're
walking around you're meeting random
people and you're running into Raiders I
literally like that aspect I'm just
getting to live in it yeah Tatooine huh
yeah that's a to mean so much does stem
from Tatooine and that planet has no I
nothing going for it now how important
to their planet is no idea and now that
Cantina has become a franchise and
there's one in Hollywood both
Skywalker's main Skywalker's right the
beacon of the dark and the beacon of
light on this one little spot was a
little desert two suns yeah I love how
that that's also a thing that keeps
coming up like the moons the suns every
planet has multiples all right ladies
and gents what did you think of this
episode leave a comment below what stood
out - you've got any predictions for the
next couple episodes would love to hear
it you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell hit
the like button or the dislike button
also I like to end us with a page in the
day shout out to a woman named - Delia
Chamberlain I was thinking to myself
before shouting you out they give you a
really sincere shout out last time
got a little misty-eyed I know you saw
it how do i top that how do I possibly
top that and I realized
I can't so this is the shadow vision for
sincerity or silliness we're just gonna
land here in the middle in the land
right here and I'm just gonna be
nostalgic about the last shout out thank
you I love you and I hope Bernie Sanders
or Elizabeth Warren wins the presidency
and if you were a Star Wars character I
think your name would be chambo a deal
it's for you
thank you John you're welcome